all right Yellow Jackets fans episode 9
the finale of season two has answered
some questions while having us ask about
a dozen more satisfying but I cannot
wait I mean who knows how long until a
season three and answers to these
Cliffhangers are actually revealed
anyway welcome back to heavy spoilers
your home for spoilers that are heavy
and in this video we're going to be
discussing everything in the yellow
jackets episode 9 and season 2 full
story breakdown callback strange
references and parallels and some
theories on where or what season 3 may
have in store for us so if you enjoyed
this video hitting that like button is
much appreciated and it helps the
channel and subscribe to heavy spoilers
to stay up to date on all of our latest
breakdowns with all of that out of the
way thank you so much for clicking this
I'm your host Jared now let's get into
Yellowjackets episode 9. quick aside we
skipped episode 8 last week sorry about
that I know a lot of you were missing it
but a quick breakdown of episode 8
basically saw all of the yellow jackets
in the past dealing with hallucinations
because of starvation which was teased
by Misty in episode 7. oh look I have um
I have some bait oh I've been kind of
hoarding food in case they decide to
enforce calorie restriction to induce
out of body experiences I think my blood
sugar can't handle that okay these
hallucinations drove them to sacrifice
someone via the card game that we had
theorized with Natalie drawing the queen
of hearts and being the mark but in the
end when Javi tried to save Natalie from
the others he instead became the
sacrifice as all stood by and watched
right where the Moose went under the
water as well this could have been how
the Wilderness actually chooses Javi was
gonna hide Natalie in his hidey hole
which is the same place that coach Scott
had found in an underground warm shelter
baby we theorize this in present-day the
police searched Jeff and Shauna's house
all of the Yellowjackets figure out
basically that Jeff
blackmailing set off a chain reaction to
bring them all together basically Adam
Martin Walter Jessica Roberts all of
them stem from this one decision of
Jeff's with the episode ending with
Lottie suggesting that the Wilderness
Demands a Sacrifice and presents a
choice of six different cups AKA Russian
Roulette Style with one of them
containing a lethal dose for one of the
women to take the ironic thing is almost
everything we know so far can be chalked
up as science coincidence you know
there's a reason behind it rather than
the supernatural elements that are now
taking a back seat okay now that that is
all out of the way let's get into
episode 9 and to be honest this was a
bit rushed and underwhelming in my
opinion yes there are some chilling
moments twists and turns but ultimately
left me like huh that that that's it but
jumping into the past the main thing
that happens is the remaining Yellow
Jackets devouring javi's body to survive
all of these scenes are almost like a
herd of animals rather than people
carrying Javi back to the camp like a
deer Shauna carves him up into hobby
nuggets serves them up and all of them
frantically toss pieces into the cast
iron during this there are also a few
things of note first being Shauna
pulling the mask over her eyes like see
no evil as an excuse to avoid her quote
bad behavior and Van's persuasion of let
Javi save you speech to Travis changed
his mentality to survive as he bites
javi's heart before the others in a sign
that the two will always be together and
javi's death needed to happen as kind of
hinted by the lyrics and meaning of the
song Killing Moon that later plays the
other big thing in the wilderness is
discovering more of why Lottie is so
messed up in present day she never asked
for the power of the group essentially
the Wilderness chose her and now she
can't hear it anymore which explains why
her decision making is kind of Twisted
by Misty throughout these last couple
episodes she didn't want to eat hobby
she didn't want the group to eat Javi
but went through it anyway and in doing
so she transfers this power to the new
quote queen bee of Natalie Natalie
avoided death and this is because the
Wilderness wanted her alive the group
accepts this almost praising her like a
deity like they did with Lottie even
with Natalie placing her hand on
Travis's chest much like Lottie did at
the beginning of this season so leading
into season three Natalie is calling the
shots but not without Shauna potentially
picking at her every single decision
because of her jealousy that we see kind
of expressed in the journal writings
towards the end the main thing in
present day is the reenactment of the
ritual hunt from the Wilderness rather
than the Russian Roulette Kool-Aid drink
idea Lottie initially suggested the
group partaken the funny thing is Lottie
is almost like a child wanting the hunt
with the others kind of being the
parents or taking on the parent role
going along with the charade like a kid
begging for candy at the candy store
like yes Lottie we will have your
sacrificial hunt to appease your
imaginary Wilderness friends don't worry
and then we'll get ice cream afterwards
lottie's case is obvious she slowly lost
her mind from the opening of this season
until now but the other member that
subtly is pulling the strings also
wanting the Hunt is Van there's some Sly
looks comments and decisions she makes
that allows the hunt to continue and
it's because deep down she still
believes in the wilderness much like
Lottie if the hunt goes off without a
hitch maybe just maybe her cancer will
be healed which we have a little theory
about that later the six of them prepare
for the hunt Gathering weapons masks
prepping the deck of cards for the group
around the fire I'm pretty sure Shauna
asked to shuffle the deck further was
her way of trying to stack the deck in
order to not pull the queen but van
calls her out saying that's enough so
I'm curious if something similar to this
has happened in the past and we'll maybe
see that in a future season anyway the
cards are picked resulting in Shauna
being the one to pull the queen I
thought that this was honestly so out of
character for everyone because instantly
they changed into like hunt mode like
killer mode the craziness of the
Wilderness who knows maybe and that's a
big maybe the Wilderness does in fact
have power over all of them but through
a series of hiccups Cali steps in then
Lisa resulting in Misty accidentally
stabbing Natalie with a syringe ending
her life this is especially traumatic
for Misty because this is now the second
time she's unfortunately killed her
quote best friend friend so did the
Wilderness choose or is this all just a
bunch of mumbo jumbo because both times
we've seen the Hunts like this uh
whoever draws the queen isn't the one
who is sacrificed in the end of things
the Hunt is a complete facade for
potentially something greater there's
also the idea that the Wilderness was
robbed of Natalie 25 years ago and had
always been tormenting her until it
finally got what it wanted this would
explain Natalie's drug use trying to end
her own life and finally perishing to
Misty honestly at this point in the
series I'm convinced that there is not
and there never has been any
Supernatural elements at all everything
can be explained away via science
conditions mental health issues and past
trauma trauma is at the core of this
series I think we're gonna slowly
realize that this show is really about
the struggle of life and how things can
stick with you throughout your entire
life as friendships and relationships
crumble and the slow toe goal of daily
life can turn you from a relatively
bright bubbly positive person into
something begging and asking for more
unhappy with your current situation
wishing life was different and again I
could easily be wrong so let me know in
the comments if you think most of what
we've seen is based in reality and it
choosing is solely the decisions a
person makes in life leading to
undesirable and even traumatic results
Natalie's last kind of Visions or
whatever mirrors that of Jackie's from
the end of season one but here adult Nat
is on an empty plane appearing to go
through turbulence this is supposed to
resemble Natalie in a purgatory-like
setting when she mentions that she's not
supposed to be there something similar
that Laura Lee said to Lottie earlier
this season
go go
[Music]
to be here this is exactly where we
belong
Natalie also sees a young Javi and a
young Lottie ushering her into the
Afterlife her final resting place though
Natalie has kind of toyed with this a
couple of times in this series Once with
her OD with Travis and another with the
Visions with Lottie that she helped or
see it's finally her time to pass on and
I want to say that this was teased
earlier in the season with her Visions
with Lottie as we have this image of an
adult Natalie wearing all white
potentially symbolizing her in heaven so
this might be a hint or a tease at
Future Yellowjackets if we see this
again in the end Natalie made up for her
not saving Javi this time being on the
opposite side of things saving Lisa
allowing her dormant empathy to get the
best of her Walter is by far my favorite
threat of this episode arriving as
Misty's night in shining armor and Saves
the Day by uh let me double check my
notes kill Kevin and blackmailing Jay
holy
yeah Walter wasn't necessarily the clean
citizen detective some of us thought he
was but rather cut from the same cloth
as Misty being a borderline serial
killer and looking back though uh there
were clear signs of this present I
assume you run Live Scan clearances and
all your hires I can assure our
caregivers are The Very Best of the Best
maybe I'm just a
board Moriarty looking for a Sherlock
I don't think that you understand the
rules of your own game there's only ever
one rule win
serial killers love puzzles it's a
documented fact Kelly
him and Misty are surprisingly made for
one another in A demented way that's why
he wanted to track her down in the first
place he had an inkling she was behind
the Adam Martin case and admired her
work as a fellow citizen detective both
were probably members of that subreddit
to make sure that no one was actually
sniffing on their Trails heck the two
even pull similar moves going into
acting mode when Kevin first enters the
room much like Misty in the wilderness
when questioned about Crystal's
disappearance poisoning Kevin like Misty
poison Jessica Roberts with the
cigarette in season one and singing
Musical songs here Walter sings Send in
the Clowns which is irony to the max
because in the musical A Little Night
Music it's used as a bit of a
distraction for the audience much like
Walter is doing here but also literally
referring to Kevin and the police as
clowns Walter is a cold-blooded killer
as we can see here shooting Kevin in the
trunk and setting up Jay but it's almost
scarier how upbeat he is when telling
Jay The Narrative again putting on a
performance telling Jay he needs more
yes and like in improv either way it
looks like Walter thought of every
single angle and is essentially a clone
of Misty I I had no clue he would swoop
in and save the day but well I guess in
an unconventional way of saving the day
the ending is a Bittersweet farewell to
Natalie as radiohead's Street Spirit
plays which is a song about being unable
to contain all of the hopelessness one
Senses at trying to Envision the
totality of death and the ultimate
uselessness of existence which we see
here from several of the yellowjacket
members Misty is devastated admitting to
Walter that she killed her best friend
this of course alluding to Natalie but
also finally admitting to someone else
along with herself that she killed her
best friend Crystal back in the
wilderness something that she had been
you know hiding and it had been eating
at her for years that she finally admits
ladius sent off to another mental
facility to get help for whatever
delusion she's still suffering from but
the interesting thing is her admitting
that they give the Wilderness what it
wanted and it is pleased now the thing
is that there is far more to this than
solely Natalie yes Natalie was the
original one who drew the queen of
hearts and is now sacrificed what the
Wilderness you know wanted and finally
got her but with the camera panning over
to Cali and even Lottie being a bit
surprised by meeting her after being
shot by her I think the Wilderness has a
hold on Cali too now something else the
Wilderness wanted shawna's baby once
again so I can see Cali now spiraling
into madness much like Shauna heck she
almost used the stolen gun on Jay so if
she follows even a small path of
Shauna's things are going to get dark
for her real quick but the thing of note
here is Lottie mentioning the Wilderness
is happy and they'll see we gave it what
it wanted
[Music]
it is pleased with us
you'll see
foreign
mentioned this while looking directly at
van and I'm betting that in season three
we're gonna find out that Van's cancer
is going to be in remission again the
Wilderness doesn't play you know the
game of one for you one for me but with
it being fulfilled it's not going to
allow another yellow jacket to perish
until it is ready so expect this
Revelation to be in the coming Seasons
I'm assuming season three but we'll find
out and I'm curious if this will also
curb Ty's sleepwalking Misty's
loneliness and Shauna's family structure
that is until it needs to be satisfied
again back in the wilderness we catch
Shauna journaling until it is quickly
turned into Panic as the cabin is on
fire with all of the girls locked inside
luckily they all Escape grabbing
supplies on the way out but it is the
thick of winter and they have nowhere to
stay or any sort of shelter obviously
this was coach Scott's dealings as we
saw him sneaking around you know with
the match is grabbing supplies and
hiding in javi's hidey hole as the girls
watch the cabin burn Killing Moon by
Echo and the bunny men plays which is a
song about everything from birth to
death to Eternity and God whatever it is
and the eternal battle between fate and
the human will hinting at no matter what
the Wilderness and life is going to
throw at them the girls are going to
find a will and means to survive the
finale gives us a bevy of ways season
three could go and potential theories to
Stew on but no doubt J is going to be on
a personal Vendetta against Shauna Jeff
basically all of the yellow jackets
we've seen that he has a knack for
gorilla detective work so I'm curious if
he'll somehow turn someone or maybe a
new player knowing of the Yellow Jackets
past will turn up as for the Wilderness
with Natalie now in charge I have a
feeling that she'll put out a hunt order
on Coach Scott I mean the yellow jackets
aren't dumb someone started the fire
coach Scott is missing oh yeah it's
Gotta Be him Natalie did talk to him
saying that he doesn't belong here in
the wilderness because he was of pure
heart he hadn't killed and he hadn't
eaten any of the other members but with
Natalie being elected as the new leader
the devilish smirk on her face tells me
that she's already switched her
mentality she's been the one who's taken
restraint and sympathy but with power
now that's going to be thrown out the
window and Coach Scott is Enemy Number
One we know he's hiding out in javi's
cave but with a brief glimpse of what
looks like his body being eaten in
episode 3 of this season I have a
feeling that Natalie and the other
Yellow Jackets will get their wish
eating coach Scott to survive the second
winter yes the second one so uh coach
Scott will still uh he he still has a
while to survive speaking of power and
Leadership Shauna's journaling is a
massive clue as to her thoughts of this
new leadership and she does not like it
so I'm guessing that every season the
power Dynamic is gonna switch or shift
somehow from Lottie to Natalie to maybe
some others in between but ultimately is
going to end with Shauna being the
antler Queen she's been the most
unhinged in both the past and present
and this journaling is a huge red flag
over jealousy much like she essentially
stole Jackie's entire life so I'm
throwing big money big money people on
Shauna being the ringleader of it all
baby and lastly that smoke signal from
the cabin burning someone somewhere is
gotta see this right I I understand that
they're in the thick of the Canadian
wilderness but the event seems to be a
turning point for someone to stumble
upon their location again the cabin is
now burnt I'm curious where they're
gonna actually take shelter maybe going
back to the plane crash and someone is
bound to see this in the distance and
could be their first interaction with
the outside world but you know if this
happens something bad is going to also
happen with this hell maybe some Park
Rangers campers hikers I don't know
locate them but then the yellow jackets
eat them I I don't know man the these
teens have been cray-cray this season
but stay tuned because early next week
we're gonna drop a whole video on
theories questions and everything that
we hope is answered in season three so
yeah get get ready for that overall I
would say that season two was a Thrill
Ride of way more weird obscure homages
and references than season one and I
kinda liked it and I kinda didn't like
season two had higher highs than season
one in my opinion shawna's whole trippy
baby episode Crystal's mid-summer fall
from the cliff and Javi reappearing only
to disappear into the yellow jackets
bellies just to name a few but the lows
were far lower than season ones I
personally felt like a lot of the middle
of this season was drawn out longer than
it could have been and the whole last
two episodes were a rush of this that
bamboom and done sure we did get some
answers but we're given far more
questions in the process so not only are
the Mysteries and questions from season
one still present but we have a bevy of
season two questions tacked on top of
those I think the acting in chemistry
this time around was far better though
again Sophie nilis is acting was superb
the range of depression from the baby
episode ranging all the way to the
ferocity of her beating lottie's ass
getting all of the surviving Yellow
Jackets together in present day was
something I was looking forward to and
the dynamic amongst them neared that of
what we've kind of seen in the
wilderness and what had played out
really painted a great kind of like
tension-filled Bittersweet meeting I'd
give this season a 7 out of 10 at the
end of the day the showrunners
absolutely know how to like keep people
invested with small little breadcrumbs
but if season three doesn't start to
fill in some of these massive blanks and
answer questions it could just be a
mundane journey through strangeness
until a piece or two fall into place
giving the viewers the much bigger
picture I thoroughly enjoyed this season
with all of the theories and headcanon
but chasing the carrot I can only get
you so far you know now I'm sure you me
everyone is clamoring for a season three
after everything in this episode like
answer hello I need some answers people
so when should we expect a season three
of Yellowjackets well
I have some good news and some bad news
for all of you fans out there uh
starting with the good season three has
been green lit and it was greenlit all
the way back in December with the show
being said to be a total of five seasons
so more Yellow Jackets is definitely on
the way but here comes the bad news
after only one day of production on
season three they had to pack things up
and halt because of the wga rider strike
that is currently in progress showrunner
and co-creator of Yellowjackets Ashley
Lyle tweeted out an updated along with
her support for the wga writer strike
saying well we had exactly one day in
the Yellow Jacket season 3 Ryder's room
it was amazing and creatively
invigorating and so much fun and I'm
very excited to get back to it as soon
as the wga gets a fair deal hashtag
Union strong of course writers should be
treated fairly but this is a blow to the
Yellowjackets fans expecting a speedy
return to the will Wilderness the
previous wga strike took place in late
2007 and concluded in 2008 lasting
roughly three months so if that is any
indication as to this present strike
season three's weight will be much
longer than the year and two months wait
that there was between season one and
season two that is everything for
Yellowjackets season 2 finale the weird
gruesome thrilling all of it obviously
there are loads of unanswered questions
and a bevy of theories we want to dig
more into so stay tuned because early
next week we'll have a full video diving
into all of that so stay tuned anyway
last month we ran a competition giving
away three copies of the quantum Mania
steelbook and the winners of that are on
screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want to support the channel for
as little as 99 cents a month then click
the join button below and as a thank you
you'll get early access to videos
everything single week just super secret
stuff we also have our merch store over
at xeroedition.com which sells a lot of
nerdy inspired t-shirts hats and all
sorts of things we've currently launched
our Peacemaker and Drax inspired t-shirt
so if you head over there right now you
do us some good you help us out then the
links are in the description and of
course if you want something else to
watch be sure to check out some of our
other cool videos right over there
classic movie breakdowns are ramping up
so stay tuned and with all of that out
of the way thank you so much for sitting
through this video for sticking along
for this yellow jackets coverage and
journey I've been your host Jared I'll
see in the next one take care and peace